so we're on our way to London very
shortly here and Jenna is filming
something Jenna testing her iPhone
underwater today
[Music]
once you're toast and I'm freezing that
I think it works he's gonna go
absolutely nuts right now
Robert Rock it's the same dog every time
he sees it he's round so you haven't
been able to tell yet
this is an iPhone vlog test I'm vlogging
this entire video on my iPhone I'm
taking Maddie for a walk right now we
just finished filming Jenna's underwater
test video if you guys want to watch
that I'll put a link to her channel in
the description below and an annotation
we are actually heading to London in
probably 10 or 15 minutes we have to
drop Maddie at Matt's house gonna go see
Matt okay you ready I think I am
are you fog yes three months same
congratulations
piston great look how big that suitcases
Sean that's two keys bigger one is
almost a suffice we made it we're late
but thankfully the plaintiff alleges Oh
it'll all work out
9:45 I mean I look like a mess there's
no Wi-Fi on this flight maybe you're 11
hours without any connections I'll
probably sleep or can't use the BRE that
[Music]
however many hours later over here
I need a coffee and then
Do It Yourself
[Music]
backed away too much there's horses
outside look horsey
[Music]
all night so we landed got to the hotel
and I thought I'm gonna go to bed now no
that's not the case
I watched sunrise I watched these horses
out there just grazing and having a
great time since I slept the entire
flight and stayed up all night my
original plan was to finish listening to
this audio booklet it started it's
called captivate and five and essa
Edwards thinking that that would help me
fall asleep but it did not but it's
about the science of people and learning
why different people communicate in
certain ways there's even like fun
little workbooks and activities that
they talk about in the book and then you
go to the website and then it's it's a
whole thing but it was a really really
fascinating book I'm extremely excited
to finish it I'm almost done you guys
wouldn't get a 30-day free trial of
audible and go to audible.com slash
iJustine or you could text iJustine to
500 500 where yeah I'm gonna go get
lunch with my sister and I don't even
know we're we got to go to rehearsals
for a live stream that's happening later
today
[Music]
today we are at a good wood house this
is an incredible estate it's over twelve
thousand acres outside of London I did a
really fun livestream before it's a
horizon for yesterday and today we're
going to do a bunch of activities
there's balloon rides we're gonna be
racing hovercrafts they also have a Ford
Raptor if you guys don't know I'm
obsessed with Ford rafters and I really
really want one so hopefully they'll let
me test drive it here today they would
not let me drive the McLaren Senna
yesterday I asked very nicely I told
them that I'm a new part of a driver and
they said no you're a liability show
today I don't know what could happen
I've got a really massive I don't wanna
call it a selfie stick but it's a it's
for a 360 camera so I can get some
really cool shots
you're gonna measure this with your eyes
my bra
you know please don't touch no don't
touch me lennier
[Music]
one two three four five six
I never thought that I needed a McLaren
until right now I mean it looks like a
small trooper it's beautiful
so I'm supposed to be on that side
[Music]
are so freaking fun guys just another
day
[Music]
[Applause]
wow wow wow that was incredible
oh my goodness well the adventure is
continuing we just got done driving the
McLaren's well being driven in them I
have to do a test drive because we had
so much fun in those cars I need to be
behind the wheel we're now going to go
on a balloon ride I've never gone under
balloon ride before our friend Susie was
in an air balloon accident so I'm not
really sure how I feel about this this
balloon is really massive I've never
actually been this close to a hot-air
balloon
[Music]
so off we go
up up and away yeah well that was really
fun I'm feeling a little busy now on the
rally car portion and Tanner is gonna be
our driver this is gonna be so much fun
we actually met Tanner years and years
ago we did this crazy test drive in
Madrid it's fun to be back I wasn't in
your car the first time this is good no
no that's right you were in just about
oh well here we are again what are we
doing today like what are we driving
this is a super rally car we're going
around a rally stage that has all four
seasons just like horizons and we're
done so we're gonna go through summer
fall winter
and spring it's going to be amazing play
ok do I get in
oh shoot that's right mr. Fong does not
pay for the wrong side okay forgetting
will get you buckled up okay this is
your first run first run oh goodness
hopefully we won't get lost trying to
find the stage I can put it in my GPS
follow the track see that's good advice
you just got good advice
myself I am
Carrie ready I'll find the start of the
stage which is over there okay
how was it over there it's pretty hot
don't know it's kind of cool but man
that's literally it's so weird to grab
gears with your left hand like this it's
gonna be fun yeah so famous last words
people boy oh my god yes we are ready
Oh
[Music]
the fun is continuing we just had lunch
and oh my gosh we just did a wild ride
previous to that with Tanner again
inside of the rally car
well but we're gonna be basically racing
the hovercraft and the rally trucks as
well so I don't know what's gonna happen
oh man this is exciting so this is a
range of Raptor so this is Canada the
European model we only have this one in
Europe but the minutes would have to
look after it just this one just this
one we're driving the only Raptor here
we are
have you seen the Velociraptor yeah
pretty cool oh my goodness guys like the
coolest thing ever
it starts around three hundred and forty
nine thousand dollars oh I hit my head
[Music]
oh boy
hit every piece of my body off his I got
a little faster in this car
how was it that was crazy
Oh a lot of grass in your face it's
probably all in my hair Wow now we're
here playing for its horizon floor this
is so much fun rainwater to sled this is
one of the non mobile ones but the other
one up there
that one actually moves around genna's
over there this game is so freakin fun
like I'm absolutely loving it I'm
driving so the horse of mine melodies
and check them out
doughnuts ready
Wow
destroy the cigarette
we're in the McLaren sauna this thing is
like a million dollars
and it doesn't matter how couple girls
this a safety harness this is a proper
racing seat belt my racing is no cup
order no cup holders that's crazy talk
right and you can't even have a drink
wow it's real nice it's really nice but
they won't let anyone ride it accidently
pulled this he's like I figure out how
to open the door I was like this looks
like ready to get out oh god I can't
even I can't even reach the door not
open the door that didn't kill like the
escape room this is fun now that I know
[Music]
warmer think higher over to the other
side closer to the front of the car
thank you wow I really need a reading
light
[Music]
I don't know I'm gonna get out of here
this is too nice
[Music]
you put this in the back before after
well today was so incredible if you guys
enjoyed this blog I'm not even sure for
this vlog to do this date justice
because it was so much fun
he keeps thinking to Microsoft and Forza
because this was just unlike anything
I've ever experienced and I'm glad I
could take you guys with me so goodbye
Duke
thank you staying over there he's home
but I didn't see him time for dinner and
then we fly back to LA but I all of the
Clarins are going away
[Music]